hidden in the natural world around us
are powerful biological tools whose
potential scientists are just beginning
to unlock for billions of years bacteria
have been under attack from viruses but
bacteria developed clever defense
mechanisms to remember these viruses and
fight back recently scientists harnessed
one of these natural tools called CRISPR
cast nine and created a powerful gene
editing technology with the potential to
treat human disease a cast nine isn't
the only CRISPR tool with applications
for human health a team of scientists
found that a cousin of cast nine called
cast thirteen can be harnessed to
actually detect human disease here's how
cast thirteen works in its natural
environment first it hunts for viral RNA
using an RNA guide when it finds its
viral target cast 13 becomes activated
in some circumstances it cuts any RNA it
encounters a process termed collateral
cleavage it is this mechanism that
scientists at the McGovern Institute
Road Institute and Harvard University
harnessed to create Sherlock a highly
sensitive tool to detect infectious
diseases in humans here's how the
Sherlock detection system works first
researchers take a sample from a patient
with a possible viral infection like the
flu then they amplify the levels of RNA
in it and add reporters that are
sensitive to cast 13 then an engineered
CRISPR cast 13 is added to the sample
this cast 13 is programmed with a guide
RNA that is designed to find only virus
RNA and bind to it when this happens
cast 13 activates its cleaving mechanism
and begins randomly slicing nearby RNA
including the reporters since each end
of the reporter carries a different
label cast 13 separates these two
signatures creating a unique signal
within the sample the sample is then
applied to a commercial flow detection
system if the sample is negative for flu
the reporter remains intact and collects
at the first detection line
if the sample is positive for flu it
collects at a different location making
a diagnosis easy to spot
so easy in fact Sherlock can be used in
the field to detect emerging infectious
diseases and outbreaks like Ebola virus
before Sherlock field samples had to be
refrigerated and shipped to labs with
expensive gene sequencing equipment now
Sherlock can be adopted to detect any
genetic signature even ones associated
with cancer in virtually any location
CRISPR casts nine and cast their teen
are just two examples of natural
biological systems that scientists have
modified to fight genetic and infectious
disease the question remains what other
tools are out there in the natural world
just waiting to be discovered
[Music]